You believe in Ufos? Oh yeah. Oh my
God. Really? Yeah. Yeah. Let's see.
I believe in,
there's other other life forms out there,
but I don't think they're coming here.
They might. Here's the thing. They might,
well, why not think it, but just
because here's, here's one thing.
I do believe most people are full of
shit when it comes to like most of their
stories,
like it's,
it's hard to find a person that could
just tell you what happened based on what
they really remember.
People want to jazz things up and they
want to add salt and pepper. Yeah.
They just sex with me that don't,
they don't necessarily tell you the truth.
They tell you what they think is going
to be an engaging story that kind of
represents the truth.
Maybe.
Especially when it's a weird thing
like you saw something in the sky.
What did you really see? How long did you
look at it for? How many seconds was it?
Well, I mean, here's the problem I have
with you for it. I believe there are,
you have photos, but I don't think they're
coming here. Why would you say that?
Because that means their tech, first
of all, if they're coming here,
that means their technology is far,
way more advanced than ours.
So why would they care if people saw them?
They would show up.
If I was an alien and I
was that far ahead of us,
I would lay in that bitch right in the
middle of time square and be like, what?
We are here. But why would you
do that? But why wouldn't I?
Why am I competing in fields
where nobody can see us?
Are you aware of how we
treat uncontacted tribes?
Yes.
To a point to point,
but what I'm saying is if
you're that far advanced,
they know if they're coming here,
they know they're,
they're way smarter than
us because they've traveled
here and we don't even know
other from far distances. We can't
even imagine. And they're here.
They don't have to hide.
It's just like they do it because they
have to hide or do you think maybe they
do it because we can't handle
it because we can't handle it?
Why would they care if we could handle
it or not? Because here's the problem.
Whenever any civilization has ever
encountered a civilization far superior to
them, the results have always been
catastrophic. Every single time.
Every time Europeans have
invaded North America,
every time the Spanish
visited the Mexicans,
every time that this has happened, it's
been a disaster. And this is human beings.
If there was something that came
down here from another planet,
it was so unbelievably sophisticated that
it could travel through vast distances
in space and had insurmountable,
impossible technology that we would
look to it for all of our answers.
It would become our new daddy.
It would completely disrupt
all of our governments.
It would disrupt all of our religions.
It would disrupt every single
belief system we have and
people would fall apart.
They wouldn't know what
to do. Psychologically, it
would be devastating. Look,
I'm not a psychologist,
but I know most people would not be
able to handle it. I understand that,
but why would they?
Because that's my whole point.
Because why would they care about
it would be affecting our culture.
They wouldn't care. But why wouldn't
they care? Well, why would they care?
We care about animals,
Bro.
There's a reason why we have
wildlife protection agencies.
We have that because we care about
animals and animals don't even know were a
thing. Okay? If you're a deer living
in the forest, you're two years old.
You might not have ever
even seen a person.
You don't even know what the fuck we are,
but we're trying to keep those deer alive.
We spend billions of dollars
every year protecting them.
We do that because we care about wildlife.
If we cared about a rare monkey that
we found in Indonesia, in the force,
I'm strange monkey.
We would do whatever we could to make
sure that monkeys populations thrive.
If there was a way to help them. I mean,
that's one of the reasons why zoos exist.
They take rare animals,
they try to breed them in captivity and,
but we're also sharing the same earth.
Would they?
Maybe they look at the universe that way
and maybe look at nuclear civilizations
like our civilization.
I mean,
our civilizations a very dangerous one
because we're a bunch of semi hairless
monkeys with nuclear weapons. I
mean, we're fucking nuts, bro. Yeah,
we're obsessed with sex. We
Jack off to our phones. We're,
we're taking pills to keep our
dick hard. We're all on speed, man.
We all have Ab. These are we're
at and we lie. We lie about shit.
We lie about things that people did to us.
We pretend people think did worse things.
We pretend that we didn't do things
to people. We lie about stealing.
We lie about money. We lie about all kinds
of things. I mean, people are so crazy.
You're thinking aliens are thinking
about all that before they come down.
Of course they would. Why
wouldn't I? Why wouldn't,
I guess I'm coming from a human point
of view where we don't give a shit about
anything is a thing that's not true.
We do give a shit about things.
That's why when you go
to the Galapagos Islands,
you're not allowed to take your shoes,
that you walked around Los Angeles and
walk around the Galapagos Island because
people have done that and they've gotten
seeds from their shoes stuck in the
sand over there in the ground over there,
and then new plants grow
that are invasive species.
They were worried about ecosystems that
we really, okay, that's fine. I Cubans,
that's where we're worried
about invasive species.